la comunidad internacional se solidariza
con Haití los países miembros de la
organización de los Estados Americanos
aprobaron una resolución a favor del
restablecimiento de la seguridad y la
democracia en la nación caribeña lo que
podría abrir un nuevo capítulo para este
país inmerso en una violenta crisis
socioeconómica y política y afectado por
un nuevo brote de cólera
la adopción de una resolución Nunca es
un fin en sí mismo son los unos y los
otros los que tienen que ponerse de
acuerdo para que las capacidades y los
medios estén allí para que todos los
deseos de este texto se traduzcan en
realidad las pandillas siempre
ejercieron Un poder considerable de Nike
pero tras el asesinato del presidente de
Rubio en el movies en julio de 2021 este
poder aumentó a medida que luchan por
controlar más territorios matando a
cientos de haitianos en los últimos
meses y expulsando a unas 20.000
personas de sus hogares el viernes el
consejo de ministros autorizó al Primer
Ministro Audi a solicitario obtener ese
despliegue de una Fuerza Armada
extranjera o de intervención que muchos
haitianos rechazan
es una acción antipatriótica normalmente
el país no está bajo tutela es un país
independiente
no está elegido no tiene legitimidad No
tiene derecho
la vuelta de la ayuda militar
internacional Allí están bien un tema
polémico por la última misión de las
fuerzas de paz de la ONU que se terminó
en 2017 después de 13 años en el país
Los cascos azules Fueron señalados por
agresiones y abusos sexuales y por
provocar una epidemia de cólera que
costó la vida de que así Diez mil
personas